welcome to this 15-minute game against
da flow from hmm paraguay yep hmm okay
got one right um okay the London system
that's not very exciting normally how to
get some action going maybe maybe could
see five can help we'd be six something
like that if I now take and then play
Queen B sixes maybe an idea maybe try
that a better way Jonathan hey this is
playing Queen B 6 the sort of pre move
can be risky somewhere person might take
on be a donkey leg with the green
especially taking on be eight then Queen
B 6 would be yeah he takes with the
Queen and it's it's really strange okay
so I'll take this temple so in a way see
fire has already proved to be a good
choice I'm getting a somewhat turn
somewhat more interesting position then
then it often happens in them in the
London system this default Bishop f4
openings they yeah they often have a
very young very dull reputation not
without justification but they are still
extremely solid and cannot expect to get
anything totally fantastic when he I'm
pretty comfortable but very often if
white plays it in a solid fashion you
cannot expect to be a more than equal
okay um my original intention here I was
Queen to be six twin be six maybe it's
got queen bee three but okay that's
that's okay let's consider i mean i
don't not really afraid of him taking
here this is not an issue maybe d5 yeah
maybe even d 5 so that hmm the other
interesting would be 94 here try to grab
the bishop very very early
yeah but ok d 55 d 5 is certainly a
logical move i'm taking the center and
okay it's not it's not taking quickly so
night if for is it move right is and
there's always be to hanging so i'm
going for that 25 25 he cannot play
because b 2 is hanging so it's not an
issue came here at take and put should
be six I guess if I'm not so easy if I
play we should be six then there is some
my g5
what I don't want to do I don't want to
take on b3 myself that's not a good idea
giving him the half-opened a far way to
have another idea what about what about
95 this could also be interesting no I'd
c5 attacking the queen or f6f six is a
good move right yeah that's a good just
bored stirring the center next move
could be Bishop e6 he's just playing the
quick quick standard moves which it's
not a bad thing probably for him and now
yeah i wonder if i should play Knights
if I have just keeping more pieces on
the board I can still take and play but
should be six
taking on g2 is is a bit lame it's not
bad but a bit bit bit lame and nights
you find he might play Quincy to simply
nothing to worry about much but but
still okay let's let's consider let's
consider the bishop PR crap taking here
bishop is 6 yeah Bishop d3 he cannot
play because of the Queen trade ok i
think i can i can do that and be should
be six outside somewhat you he would be
able to take on d5 because the rook is
not trapped anymore in the corner ok
yeah here but here i just have a six
right getting getting this bishop or
winning winning a tempo in essence
okay let's let's force that Bishop c6
Queen c6 is simply an already very much
better for like two bishops against two
nights and like as the center this looks
like something serious he probably will
drop back to d3 maybe yeah then I maybe
have to take but okay I have the half
the two bishops and end the central
control so I don't mind this a bee queen
bee three a b3 and then need to address
the age seven right happy happy for then
oh sorry I Bishop d3 I trade and play
you frog win apiece so this is not not a
problem so he probably has to go back to
e2 you know'm then then interesting i
can take on v3 or i can just drop back
maybe just going back to c7 as a good
idea keeping pieces of the water and not
giving him this double poem that might
help him with the a1 rook so I expected
we should be too maybe Queen c7 then
yeah that was certainly better than
taking on c6 okay Bishop c5 also move to
consider but it does not really help
with things if he goes Quincy too okay
I just I just drop back here Quincy to I
have oh ok I didn't expect that move but
it's an interesting choice using this
unprotected State of the bishop hmm
yeah I wonder if longer sources may be a
way to go
hmm null castles would be really
interesting if it wasn't for the pawn
being on a six Apollo a successor is
quite a problem let's say castles and G
goes to see to wear and then no takes or
takes on d5 and later somewhat sometimes
b4 b5 yeah maybe maybe this isn't
relevant because I'm I'm better in the
center anyway but still it feels it
feels a bit risky allowing this before
business one problem with long castles
is it does not protect the bishop so i'm
not i'm not really clarifying the
situation here the this is still yeah
come on let's let's let's play that I'm
falling down behind on the clock
dangerously let's let's see yeah a six
is not ideal but on the other hand I
have a good central control and it's not
like white s7 has a direct attack okay
okay if he wants to set this in motion
that b4 b5 he needs to move the Queen
and exactly in this moment this this
pinya of the poorness is resolved so I
can play em some aggressive moves myself
and wait what is doing now is taking
okay
putting a piece on c4s answered with
Knight a5 so he needs to move the Queen
somewhere c4 is bad because it gives
gives me the d4 scram okay so what now
g4 it's not helping much a g5 weakened
the f5 square quite substantially it's
not so great really
ok it's not threatening before anything
I just I just played this one it's
probably necessary in the long run
anyway getting out of this check 105 and
now i can think of more aggressive
action g4 bishop age six moves like that
ok at the moment I wonder yeah I should
come on let's let's play a bit quickly
here this is a good diagonal and you
cannot play before because of night
before those kind of little tricks
always should be a should be a hit in
the game be four night before cb4 Bishop
F to check winning the Queen ok yeah
this is blocking his beep on so I don't
mind dad ok and of course I want to I
want to keep the bishop now now I have
the idea to play efore and I'm
threatening to take on g3 because of
this pin now c4 i can probably take on a
three-play 94 with a very nice
centralized position yeah but it's this
really really doing much you for you for
up the fire yes
hmm yeah but the Queen the queen is not
doing really really much I wonder if I
should just play queen is seven and
protect this and then expel it with this
should be six pushing the pawns
afterwards be 45 is not really going to
work look T 550 525 takes on f3 yeah at
the end g3 is hanging that I don't think
this is particularly impressive this
seems fine it gives me Bishop e6 and
after Bishop e6 I can't push the pawns
further well now that's certainly okay
in this position I always have to keep
in mind that I don't need to win by a
check made it's very tempting to just
play with the bishops and yeah this
Queen takes g3 ideas and so on but yeah
in this position if we exchange all
heavy pieces for example this is just
fantastic endgame two bishops and an S
symmetrical porn structure with four
against three is got a double pawn which
is slight problem and yes this kind of
endgame would be just just fantastic to
play so I don't need to really do
something drastic him I can play with
some some patients
still if I go boo should be six yeah it
depends what is movers of course but I
do this Queenie for a five Queen a foyer
maybe now that this is not threatening
much he gets the Queen over to a forum
yeah I don't know it very much depends
on its next move as well it's very hard
to do a do-nothing move in this position
right wyd will have to commit to
something
yeah okay like this okay what is the
idea maybe something to Eve for to see
form where go here now hmm
I have pawn to e4 as well it's also
quite interesting efore and the way
night c4 might happen now that I'm not
so sure about what I could do against
that there should be six Queenie form f5
Queen a form but I have a very nice
center here that's probably just good I
can also is not doing its playing it in
a more more passive fashion okay just
just push the pawns now if you place
Bishop c4 I just drop back okay to that
I don't hmm i don't really need to react
specifically you can just push the pawns
the next again is maybe Queen f7
attacking the the night or maybe even to
take in the 95 with the temple intending
Knight g4 or 93 I think it's not working
but this is also in general an idea oh
that's oh that's a surprising decision
well again let's not not spend any more
time on that I think I should be
comfortable with the night only high if
the only thing always needs to be
checked as little tricks like Bishop a6
takes knight c6 check yeah like here
Bishop Bishop asics could be because
it's really possible that this is
threatening so important and also he's
some looking at the e6 bishop okay okay
I don't want him to take that much a
ship is six ok keep it simple um i'm
down to 2 30 mm yeah this early morning
game slave tend to be tougher than then
the ones played a bit later in the day
yeah not the ideal mate threat here yeah
okay but at least them the position is
somewhat simplified two minutes 14 every
play I'm really playing this far too
slow or too slowly yeah he really got
out of this without any any serious any
serious problems and I had had a clearly
better position so not great yes I has
simply gone too much time for for
basically nothing
and there anything I can do here at all
or touch him
learning Bishop c1 which is we add more
but maybe try to provoke something
yeah it's is just very very dry with the
opposite term colored bishops king of
one is what I expected now I can play
that check it's probably silly draw but
check yeah I can play a for should i do
that mmhmm yeah I guess so
one minute or nine that's not
particularly grade at least I've got a
pawn but it's very tough to do anything
maybe the bishop to see one try from
them
it or maybe a five-time warning doing
here he goes a 5 i'll get past a pawn
only weakness is a foralie where I can
try to attack but okay it's a draw it's
just just trying to do something but
with my bad King position it's very
tough to to make any headway cannot take
because of f3 now I king is doing
something and maybe he can take but I
don't think he should know a key cannot
if it appears on f2 it's actually
promoting yeah but this is this is
getting getting a bit tricky now I'm
getting one of those pawns it's it's
probably it's still a drop it is still a
draw
yeah this is a fortress IAM this is a
total fortress don't get any any idea I
don't think so he is trying to do
something stupid
yeah I could have played be five okay
you should never have gone off this
diagonal f1b five now we need to solve
some problems if it maybe it's it's
already already already a goner
unfortunately I have little time so I
cannot easily figure out how to best
play it ma but this looks ok
while i am going to win this unbeliever
gage could simply stay on on this
diagonal this f1 b5 diagonal and it's a
draw check check check check check check
well at least I'm awake now resins yet
the end game was was it was completely
dead he just needs to him he had the
fortress here he just needs to play this
too until the end of days that's
absolutely nothing I can do the pawn
here the porn and King blocked the King
side this is one blocking unit and also
the bishop can also go here what he does
not need to allow as me playing b5 that
I get the nape on here here already
could have done it but ok i was in sort
of a pre move mode and here i had
realized that i can do it and i think
now I'm winning I think I think I'm
winning now because he if he tries to
too cool to come with the king I have
this ideas with with getting another
pawn I think it's a win but not not one
hundred percent positive here now the
computer is not giving it as a wind only
here maybe this made it possible I need
to continue to move instantly of course
I thought that the two very far apart
pawns now this is promised to no one can
pekin he arrives in time also go here no
but here he arrives in time so this is a
draw yeah I gave my Emma I needed to
play instantly of course so what is
winning King d6 is winning ok yeah I was
pretty sure that the b5 move should win
but
so here I am quick i am very quick here
yeah okay this this is a win because the
pot is so far advanced you threatened to
go here and threaten to go to the to the
kingside yeah i really i really didn't
didn't get much I mean around here this
is this is simply excellent for black
but I totally spoiled that what was my
mistake a form that's probably not bad
deform hard to imagine the computer
gives f-4s as totally winning maybe it's
very director smooth okay I see the
point now but but not not easy just to
see here and then it wants to play rook
f8 using this pressure on the FR that's
a very good very good idea very good at
ya no i didn't i didn't see the idea at
all I mean this is the normal position
will move in a way it advances the pawns
and it should be it should be good ah I
can just take em play Queen a 525 ah
this is this is ggot I can just take
this i played this far too quickly it is
it is the correct sorry it is the
correct positional moving away keeping
peels with pieces on the board with the
space advantage but of course i can just
take it and wide resigns okay yeah now I
understand why why I'm suddenly suddenly
white good out of this because I missed
so many chances he took itself some some
real liberties there
that didn't it didn't punish them that
this was also a bit lame and here maybe
a queen e7 keeping the Queen's on but I
was at I was panicking a bit because of
the low time and thought okay let's just
keep it simple so that i can move
quicker check but of course here they're
absolutely absolutely nothing happening
yeah this this yeah it's the lateral
check but he didn't need to do that
twasn't term it wasn't necessary oh i
forgot to take on c3 here intermedia
check that that was a stupid mistake
yeah okay well i was i was panicking a
bit because i thought oh well i had such
a good position and now i need to play
this with one minute and maybe I lose on
time even as possible I mean without
increment and we just can play this here
forever yeah and that's already m said
this is a draw even after he gave like
the c-4 pond here yes the perfect
fortress can just stay here and must you
always must just block B 5 with the
bishop and then absolutely nothing is
going to happen it's quite funny that
then if you hear an engine here still
gives black minus 1 here stockfish is my
engine and well of course it's it's
totally 000 nothing nothing to be done
but the computers still have issues with
with fortress types of positions where
where this is this you can relatively
easily explained to them even a weak
player why this is a draw the computer
which is much stronger of course it's
not really calculating thinking is wrong
word calculating in terms of in terms of
setups and structures so that it can
recognize it's just absolutely nothing
going on well it was a tough game for
the early morning thanks for watching